i'm joined now by the former prime
minister
sir john major who was of course if i'm
correct
i'm actually the queen's ninth prime
minister sir john
your reflections on this day
well i think it's a very sad day
we all realized that one day it would
come and we all hope that it would be
far distant rather than near to us
so i think it is an extremely sad day
and i think there will be many tears
shed at the loss of her majesty
and sir john
we know you can't share with us
what passed between you in terms of
the conversations the regular
conversations you held with her majesty
in those meetings as as prime minister
but we've been told
it was her
her depth of knowledge and her empathy
and her her understanding that partly
marked her out
well it certainly did but but not only
that there was a great deal of wisdom
and knowledge as well there were several
things that were
very striking when you first entered
into those meetings with her majesty
firstly they were very informal
the only two people in the room were
her majesty the queen and yourself
and
a supporting galaxy of corgis who
usually happen to be there but
absolutely no one else and it was
remarkably informal uh one sat there
and we talked and there was nothing off
the agenda
everything was there that might be
raised either by her majesty or by all
by the prime minister
one reported
what was going on what was anticipated
to happen in the future what your
thoughts were about what was happening
and how you felt you were going to
handle it
and and the queen would ask questions
and she would comment
and she would refer to occasions in the
past where she had seen
similar events
and that was extraordinarily useful her
her historic memory for what had
happened
under past prime ministers was
extraordinary
and a far longer historic memory than
your civil service advisors so that was
often extremely helpful
and when it came to foreign affairs
there was almost no part of the world
the queen hadn't visited and in many
cases she would remember not just the
meetings she might have had with the
current heads of government but in many
countries their forebears had also been
heads of government and the queen had
known them as well so there was a great
wealth of knowledge that was waiting to
be tapped and it uh it just emerged
during the conversations they were
extraordinarily useful
and of the many meetings you had in the
week as prime minister
uh the hour plus that you usually spent
with the queen was among the most
valuable
and so john was that
quite
daunting one can imagine the
initial phases perhaps of your
premiership
with that depth of knowledge even just
in our own country uh when she could
quote meetings with
with titans like churchill to macmillan
and
the presidential side the eisenhowers
the kennedys
well it could easily have been made
daunting but it wasn't because of the
manner in which the queen approached it
it was very informal it was very
friendly it wasn't con confrontational
uh it so it became it became very
comfortable
of course you were always conscious you
were speaking to the monarch and a
certain degree
total respect was due but the meetings
themselves were entirely informal it
might have been as though one was
sitting at a table with you discussing
current political events in a casual and
relaxed fashion
and of course one discussed not only
the politics of things not only the
government aspect
that the queen would always have been
interested in talking about what its
impact was going to be on people in her
nation
how would things impact upon someone who
lived in wigan or seal or wherever it
may be anywhere across the united
kingdom
the personal aspect the personal impact
of policy upon people was always
something that was in her mind and that
was
amazingly refreshing and at first you
were quite astonished at the extent and
depth of understanding
that the monarch had about the lives
that
perfectly everyday people lived
and they were turbulent times
30 years ago let's talk about
for the nation on the political side of
course we we had our economic troubles
perhaps some parallels with where we are
where we are now in 2022 and of course
let's not forget there was
a violent conflict taking place
within the united kingdom that peace
process that you started to negotiate
and uh
her majesty the queen
kind of
symbol of stability amongst all that
her majesty
was a unifier
she was extraordinarily interested in
the peace process and how the peace
process was developing and how far we
thought it would go and who we could
bring in to help who were the people who
were actually standing in the way what
were the problems that existed how did
we think we could overcome it did we
think a solution was possible how long
would it take all those were the sort of
matters that we would have discussed
but her interest in ending the divisions
indeed the hatreds
and and and the problems that existed in
northern ireland her interest in seeing
that solved was remarkable
and one of the regrets i think i have in
my public life was that we weren't able
to finish that it was very ably finished
by my successor tony blair and his
advisers afterwards and i warmly commend
them for having done that and brought
about the
the final agreement
and i think if i had a regret it's that
i didn't finish it
and if i had a second regret it would be
that when the queen made her remarkable
visit to uh ireland a few years
afterwards uh that i was out of
government and no longer there but her
interest in that was total
and and just while we're on that sir
john
you mentioned that visit to northern
ireland that
remarkable scene
symbol of forgiveness when she shook
martin mcguinness's hand former head of
the ira the ira that it murdered dickie
mountbatten
it was a remarkable uh moment of
forgiveness it was a remarkable act of
statesmanship
states womanship i should say
and it took a remarkable woman to do it
but it was necessary
she knew it would help
and she was prepared to do it
i have absolutely no doubt that she was
entirely happy to make that visit
and to make the gestures that were
necessary to seal the work that was
coming towards fruition
and it was very valuable she was as i
said a unifier that was her natural
instinct her natural instinct was not to
create division but to bring people
together and whether that was bringing
people together within northern ireland
or bringing the component parts of the
united kingdom together when they had
disputes her principle was the same
unity
is far better than division
and so john then those difficult years
for the royal family for the monarchy
itself from the anna cerebelists we
heard her referring to in her christmas
address the
destruction of windsor castle the
separation and divorce of charles and
diana and then ultimately the
the sad passing
of
the princess of wales such difficult
times
they they were very difficult times in
the 90s i mean janus rivals and and the
the fire at windsor in in 1992 i
remember very plainly indeed
and
the queen in times of difficulties
is stoic
she doesn't panic she doesn't go into
her shell
she puts her head down she realizes
there are difficult things you have to
live through you put your head down you
plow ahead and eventually you will come
out the other side it's it's a great
gift that stoicism and it is a gift that
she learned and she understands that you
will come out of it horrible things have
happened to people before and they do
survive them they do come out the other
side and that was something she fully
understood
whatever happened the daffodils will
come up next spring
and so let us get on with life it was a
very uh profound way to approach many of
these problems
what a great way to end our conversation
what a memory to take with us sir john
thank you so so much for sharing that
with us so john may great pleasure the
former prime minister of some of his
memories